[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream Q&A section our 25th
right yes ok 25th good we are now ready
to to address ASD your Q's that's what
we do that's what we do that's what we
do ok we're going to start with one that
we passed that we read but passed over
last time because neither of us
recognized the term it was why is the
Gini coefficient not part geg ini why is
the Gini coefficient not part of the
conversation even though it explains
clearly that inequality is the root of
crime the West is the 1% of the world
but we only see what's close to us thank
you
so I'm embarrassed to say I did not
remember what the Gini coefficient was
but it is a measure of inequality
effectively a measure of the
concentration of well-being as measured
by wealth in a society so I would say a
it should be front and center in our
discussions but I would say you need to
be slightly cautious about the
conclusion that the coefficient reveals
that inequality is the root cause of
crime because although I believe that
that is likely to be true there's a
question of cause and effect here so you
could argue potential Wow my god yes the
people wolf you could argue that other
causes would create the concentration of
well-being and crime or you could argue
that crime actually causes a decrease in
wealth accumulation in certain sectors I
don't think either of these things are
liable to be true but nonetheless you do
it is too simple to say that it simply
reveals what it does reveal is that
there's a correlation between these
things it doesn't doesn't tell you what
the the pathway is yep good hard to stay
on on track when your people wolf comes
into the room it's very frightening when
a wolf enters the room on announce yeah
what are you gonna do floppy ears Oh
okay first question from livestream that
we just did is it plausible that the
epigenetic signals of our environment
represents a primary genetic code and
DNA a secondary one is the environment
the instrumentalist
and are we its instruments thank you for
your leadership did you get it you
understand what they're asking okay yeah
took me a while to Depar sit but then I
I got it I think this is an incredibly
audacious question yeah I think it is
almost certain to be a blind alley I
don't think there's anything down this
road I think the genes have to be
primary and then epigenetics happens on
top epigenetics including things beyond
the molecular epigenetic mechanisms that
have become so fashionable to discuss
but it's audacious in a way that is
testable and scientific unlike say pants
psychism yeah right so i mean i i'm i
enjoy the question i don't think it's
right
i don't know anyone who's investigating
it i don't know it is a live hypothesis
and active in practicing scientists
heads right now but the idea that
epigenetics is first and genetics is is
is less fundamental there's an
intriguing one well let's put it this
way i love the way i love the instinct
to take the most fundamental assumptions
of a system and to just try flipping
them on their heads to see what happens
because every so often you do that and
the world makes more sense not less and
i you begin to wonder is that assumption
way off or why just cancel out a bunch
of terms that were plaguing me right
exactly so anyway keep up with that
style of logic and if you're right and
we're wrong man you're set that is a
great and that is a great idea to
explore yep next question in episode 23
at time stamp permit in episode 23 at 32
minutes three seconds you said that
intermediate understanding of evolution
is not enough to analyze cognition
across populations because quote it's a
different kind of inheritance I know
this is the worst subject but please
expand I hurt you all right I'm going to
expand a little this is something that
really requires a great deal of care the
thing is people do not understand
what it means that something is
heritable heritable has a very narrow
definition inside of biology and so
narrow is it implies in this case that
the the percentage of the variance in a
trait that is accounted for by genetic
differences and certain very odd things
happen when we define heritability this
way things traits that are fixed things
that we all share by fidelity bipedality
for example their heritability goes to
zero which in common parlance suggests
that they are it's not genetically
encoded which is exactly not what it
suggests so anyway there's let's just
say there's a landscape of things that
go on in and around the concept of
heritability that is totally
counterintuitive and you would have to
understand them well in order to know
what the claim that X Y or Z is
heritable actually implies so one thing
the example I think I use this with Sam
Harris on his podcast and when I was on
it you could take a trait it could be
skin color it could be no shape it could
be any trait right and it could be
associated with a kind of prejudice in a
society and that trait could therefore
have impacts on how you were treated if
you had it versus didn't have it and it
might then have impacts on how capable
you ended up on some tests that we gave
you and it would show up as heritable it
would actually be heritable right if I
had a nose shape that made people think
I was a dummy and so they didn't put
things that were mentally enriching in
front of me as a kid and I ended up less
well-off mentally than I otherwise would
have if that's a common pattern then the
point is my X perfectly with no shape
right no shape is variable it's not
fixed so my nose shape tends to predict
what I will experience and that then
becomes a heritable component of
intelligence but the point is to say oh
such-and-such a percentage of
intelligence is heritable or the
difference in between two populations is
heritable you don't think well it may be
its heritable through the following
route I've got a nose shape that causes
people not to treat me seriously in an
intellectual
way and that has impact right that is
heritable but it doesn't mean what you
think it means it doesn't mean there's
anything in the genes that specifies
these differences now here's a tough
part okay you probably ought to sit down
are you waiting for them to sit down I'm
given in a minute - sure find a chair
right if I or make one I need more than
a mat okay well we'll just skip ahead if
your pause and then you can come back to
it if you're making your own chair but
the problem in this case is wait I've
lost my train of thought I'm sorry was
the chair there's the chair thing not
difficult the truly difficult thing in
discussing heritability is this yeah
the truly difficult thing in discussing
heritability is this the fact of
population level differences in
intelligence has to have existed in
history in evolutionary history in order
for us to have gained the
disproportionate intelligence that we
have as a species in other words they
will have to have been populations that
had less of it and they will have to
have been out competed by populations
that had more so I'm not denying that
differences between populations could
exist however that is not to say that in
the present those differences that we
see and the differences are real the
question is really about their cause
also the degree to which they are
representative across the board in other
words you could test some very narrow
kind of intelligence and you could be
thinking that it was overly important or
more important than it actually was
given that if various different kinds of
intelligence but nonetheless the
question is do we currently have
differences between populations that owe
to genetic differences between them that
account for disproportionate
intelligence in some populations and
less of it in others and I don't believe
that we have evidence that strongly
suggests this we have the population
level differences we have heritable
differences between those populations
but what the mechanism of action here is
is really not clear and so in any case
there's not enough room to really go
deeply but I would just say you would
want to run an experiment that we cannot
run in order to know the answer to this
and the experiment involves a
completely equal society in which the
prejudices do not exist and therefore we
could see whatever residual heritability
in intelligence differences existed when
you had controlled for things like the
different culture in the household the
different propensity for to have two
parents or maybe two parents and an
extended family contributing to the
raising of offspring so anyway there's a
lot of confounds here and my personal
expectation is that genetically encoded
differences in cognitive machinery will
account for very little approaching none
I can defend that further at some other
time but there you go
given the correlation between
socioeconomic status and reproductive
strategies if we want to increase
equality of opportunity wouldn't it make
sense to implement policies that promote
marriage and strengthen families yes yes
absolutely
families are a let's put it this way
human babies are disproportionately
helpless the term we would use
professionally is altricial they as
opposed to precocial the generic term
being precocious but it's nice I could
the same thing but we're born helpless
rather than skillful we've won super
helpless super needy and we are not
blank slates but blank our than any
other creature and therefore we have a
lot more room to get upgraded by having
more intel around to convey their
particular kinds of insights and
intelligence to us which we've then pick
up so yeah more adults who are in stable
relationship with us and with each other
and who love us and are interested in as
as children as babies love us as babies
and children and who are interested in
giving their best shot at raising us
having having more than one caregiver in
your life who does that well allows you
to calibrate the wisdom of each or all
of them in a way that if you only have
one primary caregiver it's much harder
to do yeah absolutely
so I would also say this
question is obviously motivated by the
claim that we can do away with the so
called nuclear family and replace it
with extended communities and this is
this kind of garbage utopian idea I hear
it now coming out of this movement I've
also heard it thrown about in
polyamorous circles and here's the thing
unless you understand what the argument
is about group selection and whether
group selection is an important force in
evolution you're not in a position
really to evaluate the likelihood that
you could swap this other mechanism in
because the fact is there's a very good
reason that families do this job well
and when you say well we'll just swap in
this other thing
in lieu of families you are making a
claim about something being
evolutionarily stable that some of us
would argue is absolutely not going to
be evolutionarily stable so this is why
we need stem because it said it's
inherently a stem question yep thanks
guys for the clarity what are the
chances that repeated spaced out below
threshold exposure to cope at 19 we'll
end up conferring immunity
similar to diluted virus after passages
greetings from Peru LRU : spaced out
that's what I want I don't know what
after passing we're first so I know what
the question means I wasn't quite sure
what the analogy for to passage a past
meeting is the laboratory technique oh
yeah so the question is asking if you
didn't come down with Cove at 19 but you
were exposed repeatedly to Stars Cove -
would that exposure trigger immunity
your immune system seeing fragments
basically what it's arguing is like a
vaccine well we have there is some
evidence and with Kovan 19 it's so hard
to know what that we think is true is
true there's been so much bad data and
so much bad analysis of the data that
are there but I have seen evidence that
looks compelling to me from what I can
judge of of the data that there's
actually been some background immunity
to coronavirus and populations that were
imagined to be naive to it suggesting
that exposure potentially to other
coronaviruses might be conferring some
immunity
and so if that's true I think it
possible that you might end up with some
low-level immunity to the novel
coronavirus with this sort of background
low level of media it's not exactly the
same yeah you're talking about you're
talking mighty different things but but
that first result that I that I just
mentioned is incredibly hopeful the idea
that exposure to some of the other
rotating you know out there
coronaviruses can confer some background
immunity for the novel Crona virus is
exciting it's actually one of the few or
the rays of hope and this whole pandemic
yep
although I have the the darkness that
will absorb that ray of hope as always a
paper recently emerged that suggested
that even people who had been infected
I think I'm understanding it correctly I
only briefly looked at it but even
people who had been infected by SARS
Cove who didn't necessarily cero convert
and therefore we're testing negative on
these antibody tests which also implies
a likely failure of immunity going
forward I think that's correct yeah now
you showed me I think you just showed me
the abstract but the idea would be that
the t-cells kicked in enough to allow
the person who had been sick to get
better but then no memory cells were
generated such that you might have had
immunity for a week or two
I'm just making those numbers up but
after being sick with coven 19 but if
you didn't see her convert then you had
no immunity you know within a month
after being sick this is just terrifying
there's a lot of speculation here one
likely would be the t-cells that did the
work which would then fail to create the
b-cells that would create memory cells
that would give you lasting immunity we
don't know what any of the mechanisms
are frankly we don't even know that this
result is true you know you wouldn't
really want to see this result
replicated but if this result is true it
does suggest a there may be a more SARS
curve to circulating out there than we
know because it's evading our tests
better than we think and B that the idea
that if you had it your immune might not
be true in this case which would be
really bad
yep absolutely thanks for the darkness
man you're welcome
racism so this is written a little bit
telegraphic Lee I'm gonna try to spell
it out
racism accorded D'Angelo is a system and
all reliable sources constitute a belief
in her world her whole claim is based on
changing the term while maintaining the
inherent gravity of the accusation if
true
how long until Webster's at all
capitulate it's a great question and of
course one of the dictionaries already
has capitulated I don't have I didn't
see this question coming so I don't have
the reference but there's an article a
week or two ago suggesting that some
high school kid had been writing into I
don't know if was Webster's it wasn't
the OED but it was one of the big big
dictionaries and basically argued for a
new definition that of racism that
tracks with this sort of systemic vague
unfalsifiable can't ever get beyond your
own inborn original sin racism
definition that many in the black lives
matter are trying to force upon us and
the dictionary did capitulate so how
long yesterday
yep that's not long yeah it's a it's a
toughy you know all of these terms
there's not even really a good answer to
what you're supposed to do because the
fact is terms do naturally evolve what
do you what happens when somebody it
takes charge of that process and they
redefine white supremacy and racism
right out from under you and they define
them as really mundane things are you
begging the question here I'm yes the
answer is Mary um but there is the thing
that troubles me terms change maybe they
change at lightning speed and you still
need to update the dictionary but here's
the thing and actually the question
alludes to it I've said in the past is
the problem is that the threshold for
triggering these terms has been lowered
so you can't possibly avoid tripping
over it right of course you're racist of
course you support white supremacy how
could you not right and then you've got
a definition that supports the oh yeah
you're you know even you know if you
sleep silently that's you in
gauging in violence against you know
minorities or something right yeah but
the point is at the point that you say
well I guess then and the penalty phase
it goes right back up to the old
definition so it's not even that it's
been redefined right it's like as soon
as you agree that white supremacy is you
know it comes out of the tap right as
soon as you agree to that then the point
is it's as if there are crosses burning
on everybody's long and that ain't the
way it is so even the redefinition
process doesn't quite capture because
the point is we're gonna redefine it for
these purposes and we're gonna keep it
to find the way it was for those
purposes and that's how we're gonna get
you yep it's a trick yeah it's a trick
the scariest aspect of the science
shutdown was the potential permission
this movement gave itself if science is
racist the movement can or must be
unscientific to avoid being racist was
this intellectual looting the ultimate
goal of the science shut down yeah so we
did I think it was episode 22 maybe in
which we talked a lot about the shut
down stem and yes certainly there
hand-in-hand and you know what is what
is the benefit of shutting down stem is
it you know honestly to get a stall
reflect on our internalized an
externalized racism or is it actually go
after science and logic and
enlightenment values altogether and you
know there's nothing on the black lives
matter webpage that I saw I haven't
looked at all of their sub pages that
goes directly after stem but they're
proudly going after the nuclear family
and promoting you know trans lives over
you know
other people's lives and they were hand
in hand with shut down stem just not
formally it's all of a piece yeah it is
all of a piece so I'm reminded of your
adviser
Arnold Kluge and his very wise file
cabinet yes his office the note on the
file cabinet said it's about power and
limited resources stupid
all of these moves I don't know why
people were scared of him wonderful the
this is all about power all of it the
pulling down of the statues the
redefining of the terms the setting up a
black only section of the lawn in the
Chas all of the chop sorry just um sorry
all these things are about power getting
science magazine in nature magazine to
broadcast shut down stem it's all about
power and it all comes with like a
little fallback position so as that
evergreen where they did want every
single white person to leave campus for
a day they did have a 200-seat workshop
which couldn't possibly accommodate all
of us so they could just say well it
wasn't for everybody you're overreacting
right so anyway these things the little
protective fallback for shut down stem
is well it's linked for a day but no
didn't you just get science magazine
reacting right you're that productive
every single day can't you just take a
day Brett to reflect on your internal
racism can you take a day taking plenty
of really clear that you're not going to
take that day yeah I think if anyone has
it same but anyway yes the don't be
fooled by the little fallback positions
it's nonsense
shut down stem really is about shutting
down stem and yes this is rationalizing
the saying of illogical things the
foregoing of analytical tools that's
what they're doing yeah we did that one
what advice would you give to
professor's at private universities that
will soon face or are currently facing
what you two-faced at Evergreen mmm
you're trying really hard not to say
quit I mean it depends a week ago maybe
I would have said it depends on where
you are and you know I've I've given a
couple of talks in which you know one at
the Department of Justice in which I was
asked you know what advice what you
would you give and I separated out
between faculty admin and students I
find faculty the most complicit in in
this madness
and if you are faculty who do not have a
complicit in the madness administration
behind you you have no excuse and you
can stand up if however you would all
doubt the administration that you have
and the reason I say as of a week ago
that was my advice and as of now
University of Chicago even is willing to
investigate one of its own esteemed
professors for a tweet that is patently
not racist skepticism yes for skepticism
well University of Chicago is the is the
bastion of hope and I don't know how you
couldn't be sure that your
administration has your back unless you
have a clear honest and deep
relationship with an administrator who
really can protect you but you know
individuals standing up against this
madness if the administration will fall
in line to the new religion don't stand
much chance how how if you do feel like
you either need to because it's who you
are or you maybe can't afford to how
would you say you stand up well I'm
gonna give I've gotten over my little
episode of darkness and in any case I'll
give you I'll give you my real advice
but almost nobody's going to be in a
position to do anything with it for
various reasons the thing you should do
is you should look around you should
figure out who else on your campus has
courage courage and integrity it's not a
big list you find those people though
and your reason with them and you say
what our colleagues would not hear when
we approached them but might be more
visible now which is look this ends very
very badly and either you attempt to
bootstrap a response that has some new
effect you try to figure out what
response might halt the juggernaut at
your college and the problem is you
probably fail but the logic here is the
same one that nobody seems to like
except me
about the the first against the wall'
club which is once you realize that you
can't actually buy yourself anything
other than a brief respite that you can
sacrifice your own integrity and you can
get a brief respite but you can't get
any permanent refuge from what's coming
then the point is well which would you
rather would you rather hold on to your
integrity and say what you really think
and see if you can arrange some kind of
response that allows you to survive in
spite of that even though it probably
won't work or do you want to pretend to
believe things that you don't believe
for the rest of your career and
effectively become you know a I don't
know even know what you are at that
point yeah an effective collaborator one
thing I would add yesterday sort of
logistical level and answer this
question what would what advice would
you give is that there is a growing
literature that points out that things
like the implicit bias test and equity
and diversity training are actually not
just not effective but but negatively
effect they aren't productive
counterproductive I cited a couple of
them in my piece on college presidents
which I might if I think of it might dig
up in place here but I've got a piece on
college presidents where I think some of
these pieces are but there's more that
scholarship is actually growing I think
already by then so that piece came out
maybe two years ago one year ago and
there was already a lot of evidence to
suggest that the implicit bias test
which emerged from Harvard was just not
reliable can be gamed
and the results are not reliable but
increasingly there's evidence that these
diversity inclusion and equity workshops
the vast majority of them are
counterproductive and so perhaps arming
yourself with some of some of that
literature you know given that you're in
an academic environment trotting out
peer-reviewed literature to the
administrators who are trying to force
you to take these kinds of workshops
might be a first step
yeah they won't listen and the problem
is that the purpose of these things
isn't the advertised purpose anyway oh
actually one other thing I was reminded
actually
valerie tweeted something to this effect
today and you know she we've talked
about her before on his podcast he'd
been on the podcast right but she's been
and she's just she's a friend of ours
and she's fabulous and her one of the
things that she does is offers dia
training stood diversity inclusion and
equity he died trainings but she does so
with integrity and honesty and care with
an actual goal and I think effect of
getting people to talk about the
differences of their experiences so that
they can come so that you know whatever
the team is can come together with a
shared understanding of who they all are
and so she was the reason that she was
in Portland and you know stayed with us
and was on the podcast back in September
of last year was because she'd been
hired to give one of these trainings for
a bunch of FAA people right and she's
available like I covered I'd love to see
her star rise in this regard to see her
be a kind of golden Trojan horse walking
into these trainings where people expect
the same all divisive anti-racist
garbage and instead they get Chloe and
her theory of Enchantment that would be
amazing
yeah also suggesting hurts theory of
Enchantment Chloe Valerie is the is the
founder and the she just does amazing
work she's the opposite of a Trojan
horse I'm trying to have a little occur
to us when when we're done with the Q&A
here but yes I if you are inside one of
these entities and you are trying to
figure out what you might do it would be
a very wise idea to take the genuine
article and substitute it for the
reeducation camps that is the intent of
these other things with Chloe Chloe
rather than the people brandishing the
modern little red book yep
for sure next question could you please
go deeper or guide me to a video where
you explain how you break away from
evolutionary truth and live a morally
and ethical live a moral and ethical
life
so I I know where this is coming from
that it's not exactly breaking away from
evolutionary truth but are in our
evolutionary foundations and the drives
that we have that are evolutionary and
that are that are real but not honorable
it is it is one of the main themes of
the book that we are writing that will
be out in hopefully less than a year in
spring of next year other than that well
I want to I want to challenge the
question a little bit okay
I think the key actually to doing what
you're talking about involves staring
directly at evolutionary theory because
when you realize what it is that your
genes are trying to arrange and that
some of the things that they have set
you up for are magical and tremendous
and some of the things that they have
set you up for perfectly ghastly and
that at some level you are either going
to make an is aught failure you're gonna
engage in the naturalistic fallacy and
you're going to embrace everything
evolution thinks is cool
or you're gonna reject it you say you
know what no my values don't fit that
I'm gonna choose the things that I like
from evolution and I'm going to resist
those things that my genes would have me
do that I don't believe are honorable
right that's it the basis tribalistic
impulses for instance sure I mean you
know look it's no secret to anybody who
studied evolution that rape is an
evolutionary strategy did you engage in
it [ __ ] no that's that's completely
abhorrent so that if you can see that
much it's one sentence right you're not
on board with rape then you are already
dividing what it is that evolution might
point you towards and choosing some and
rejecting others and the point is okay
now take that model and take it over the
entire spectrum of things and you'll
find it there are things that evolution
wouldn't have you do that are well worth
your while and there are things that it
would have you do that you best not you
must not and but understanding what what
of our drives our evolutionary and have
been effective at some points for some
of our ancestors in the past and are
therefore why they persist is an
important piece of the puzzle and
understanding how to then unhook those
things from our current motivational
structures yep
many BLM and Tifa motives BLM slash and
Tifa motives make sense to me within the
US progressive lineage but for some
reason the Robyn D'Angelo white
fragility doctrine gives me strong
Puritan vibes very creepy do you agree I
mean I see it as a mechanism right in
order so when it when you deploy all of
these little Kafka traps you trigger
people who can spot the Kafka trap you
trigger them to resist and say no I'm
not stepping in your damn trap at which
point you have to have it you know what
do you do next and then thing is that ah
white fragility it's all that coming
yeah so you know is that Puritan I I'm
not so sure I think it's just um sneaky
which doesn't strike me as particularly
pure yeah I mean it it reminds me of
some elements of Christianity in terms
of the original sin and you know no no
escaping it and such but I wouldn't I
don't I don't quite see the Puritan
connection either I do see creepy but I
think this is this is right Brett it is
it has been adopted as a strategy on to
you know being being warned by the sort
of BLM and Tifa things and you know my
part of me objects to this the premise
the first sentence in this question
which is that many BLM and Tifa motives
make sense to me within the US
progressive lineage as as people within
the US progressive lineage I think you
know I find so much abhorrent there and
yet yet I do see at foundation a number
of the things you know they there there
has been a history of for instance
Marxism in progressivism in the u.s. and
that's never you know we've urban
Marxists and that's not what what we are
engaging in but is that has that been a
long-standing part of some part of
progressivism in the u.s. it has sure so
you know that that much is true
yep so I would say also white fragility
is two strategies okay it's a strategy
for the movement it's also a marvelous
strategy
to advance the cause of Robyn D'Angelo
oh yeah
who is getting fantastically wealthy and
famous and powerful and it's weird
because she's white and so she's like
figured out how to sell out all sorts of
people who are actually innocent of the
crime in exchange for it's like it's it
she's transferred so much well-being to
herself by becoming the you know the
queen of this insane
ideology instead of false claims it's
really well done Robin yeah very of
someone a year ago or so on Twitter said
to me something about her being a
scholar I said she's about as much of a
scholar as Donald Trump is but the two
of them share shares something which is
a deep-rooted narcissistic ability to
look out for number one mm-hmm and to
really promote number one at the cost of
all sorts of people around them she's
wickedly good at it now I did see a
response to my suggestion again on
Twitter just before we began the
livestream today that white fragility
was akin to the little red book someone
said uh Heather you're too late actually
BLM is now going after white fragility
precisely because it was written by a
white woman and now she's being
denounced it's like well you know it
could have happened to a more
appropriate person I can't help but have
some sympathy if they finally come for
her but god damn it oh yeah I mean you
were warned the left eats itself that's
what's going on yep I did some research
into the McRaven yang idea well I like
your intent I don't trust this pair I
would suggest representative Dan
Crenshaw of Texas and Eric Weinstein
that's love and respect to you both
never heard of either Italy our producer
also our son is in the other room
laughing now here's the thing I'm not
sure exactly what to say I believe
McRaven yang is the right pair they will
have to be drafted lots of things could
happen the most important thing to
recognize is that the plan is viable if
it can be populated by a
that makes sense so I have laid out
criteria there are only three I would
say there's a kind of a fourth one
haunting to the three criteria for the
two right of center in the left of
center our patriotic courageous capable
okay we need two people and one from the
left one from the right that have those
characteristics be very desirable if
they were also well known so I would
certainly trust Eric in this position
I'm not sure you know given that I
advanced the plan I'm not sure how it
would strike people but whatever he's on
a very short list of people who would be
highly qualified for the left of center
part of that puzzle I know Dan Crenshaw
as well but in any case the important
thing is that we defeat the duopoly that
we defeat the duopoly with a plan that
actually allows the power to move us
forward and who inhabits that plan is
secondary
so anyway suggestion taken okay we'll do
a couple more here and then we'll switch
to the other livestream questions
heterozygous tay-sachs and torsion
dystonia definitely boost IQ about ten
points even controlling for ethnicity
Cochrane it all says it implies group
differences in IQ why else select for
homozygous bad stuff that's a good
question
I don't do you know the torsion dystonia
example no I don't know what that is I'm
only vaguely aware of it exists you're
basically right that you would select
4-bit well no there are a couple reasons
you would select for bad stuff in the
case of these things the reason that you
would select for it is that it comes
coupled with positive traits that
outweigh the negative I still don't
think we have enough information about
the the mechanisms involved and what
sort of heritability we are looking at
there are lots of possibilities and we
don't have the answer so
it's on the table of possibilities 10 IQ
points is significant it is not decisive
but in any case we need to look deeper
into these things and we need to do so
with an upgraded understanding of what
heritability is because otherwise we're
just going to keep tripping over the
same kinds of errors where we think we
were saying something when we say
heritability that we're not okay
violence in great apes compared to
humans for evolutionary advantage
thoughts on non-violence and cultural
evolution question mark thresholds where
violence creates evolutionary advantage
you turn that into a cent less turd for
me how much I'm not I'm not sure exactly
I sort of have the sense that the
question is you've got cultural
mechanisms increasing what many call
pro-sociality and thereby decrease
violence and so they're looking for a
comparison with great ape models where
presumably those cultural mechanisms are
much less elaborate which is true
although they also I mean group size is
such a good predictor of both degree of
sociality and therefore violence that
interestingly humans have by far the
biggest group size of any primate but
baboons which are not apes have the next
biggest group size have you know you
keep very high rates of violence and
then you know chimps tend to have bigger
groups than gorillas and have higher
rates of violence bonobos which your
sister two chimps both both Gina span
have similar group size to chimps but
have lower rates of violence so it's
there's it's more it's more than just
group size it's more than just great
apes versus humans
yeah it's complex and in fact the
bonobos are a really interesting example
I'm not convinced we understand them
very well yet but the fashion thing I
mean they're sorry but you know Leakey
did not put anyone on the on the job of
spending decades
and I'm sure that there are at this
point some people trying to do long term
behavioral work on bonobos this has been
done on the three other species of great
apes and chimps are rangs and gorillas
but I don't even I can't call up the
name which says something you know for
someone deeply embedded in animal
behavior and you know and this sort of
thing so I don't I don't think good
longitudinal work on bonobo social
systems has been done we have a couple
of things that everyone likes to trot
out around sex for food trades and being
less violent and you know almost being
matriarchal and all but it's it's much
more scattershot in anecdotal it's
scattershot I think some of that has to
do with the practicality of studying
bonobos existing over just much smaller
range and places where it's hard to
study them but but I would just point
out I think our understanding of what
happened so we split from chimps six
million years ago if yeah from the most
recent common ancestor of us chimps and
bonobos right and so the chimp lineage
split into two much more recently like
two million years ago don't actually
know when that is supposed to have
happened but in any case my
understanding of the story is that the
chimps and gorillas lived in overlapping
ranges and the gorillas in this range
went extinct which opened a niche for
chimp like organism to move into
gorillas space so the fact that that had
profound influence on the behavior of
the chimp lineage that sprung off at
that point is interesting especially if
it took them in the direction of reduced
violence because of course gorillas are
less violent than chimps a lot less
violent so anyway there's something to
be said that hints at an ecological
interaction with this that may have an
important role that we haven't yet
understood so anyway it's worth it's
worth thinking about what the
implications of that are if I even have
the story right I'm I'm not a
primatologist yeah I don't I I don't
know of that piece and when you said it
it made me wonder you know well was it
the chimps that drove the gorillas
extinct just as you know homo homo drove
other
Australopithecus and such don't believe
there's any evidence of that I think it
was ecological no major
okay so let's find if I can figure out
where it is ah here we go
Zach do you have a line here on where
the new questions are or can you just
tell me what line I'm looking for oh
it's right there no no that's not right
mmm no because yeah but I only had 32
questions from before so I'm just gonna
go to line 32 oh boy if that is true if
they didn't all come in then guys I'm
really sorry we missed a lot of your
questions we will try to collect them
and return to them yeah these were not
in in before all right here we go
a friend of mine told me that sex and
gender are different sex being
biological and gender being more fluid
and social true or BS kinda yeah so so
feel like writing a teen books on this
no no I think we got we got one sentence
well so okay go for the one sentence one
sense is gender is the software of sex
does that make it more flexible yes but
gender is the software of sex gives us
the correct inference which is that this
is not a completely free variable this
is also subject to evolutionary
pressures and evolutionary history there
is much more reason to expect variation
between populations and how this
parameter functions there's also reason
to expect that we have more room going
forward to change gender than we do sex
but the to say that gender and sex are
different is not to say the thing that
is usually implied when people invoke
that which is that gender is an
arbitrary landscape that
you're free to choose you recognize that
wasn't one sentence right there was one
that was about the eight sentences I was
going to say about let me let me let me
also say you know I have written about
this a fair bit already and spoken about
it in various places in non-human
organisms the thing that we call gender
in humans we call sex role and it's
effectively the behavioral component
that is mostly predictable from what sex
you are and so for instance in the much
trotted out by the trans rights
activists generally not what I call true
trans but in the trans rights activists
like to point out hermaphrodite xx
switching fish sequentially
hermaphroditic fish reef fish like clown
fish and damsel fish and such which as
if that suggests that people can do the
same thing and of course it means no
such thing but what happens in these
fish is for depending on the ecology of
the particular species at the point that
a male switches to a female actually
switches to a female goes from producing
sperm to producing ovaries has
anatomical and physiological changes
that accompany that that are also about
the sex but also changes the behavior
from male typical behavior to female
typical behavior and the behavior is the
gender it's the sex role so are there
things that men and women do that are
sex
typical sex stereotypical if you wish
that that are true across cultures yeah
less so across all cultures than within
cultures are the things that we
behaviorally do that aren't absolutely
mandated by our anatomy and physiology
like breastfeeding and gestating and
ejaculating and things like this are are
things that are behaviorally following
from sex more flexible and malleable
than sex itself for sure but of course a
lot of the trans ideology that is being
trotted out suggests that the behavior
is the same so I mean they're they're
doing a kind of a motte-and-bailey thing
where they
we're only talking about gender and then
they'll also claim in the next breath
that sex isn't real either so sex and
gender are different but gender follows
from sex and yes we can unhook some of
the traditional expectations of gender
roles usually that's not in the room we
can unhook some of the traditional
expectations of gender roles as we come
to understand why they're there okay
Hale professors the orienting reflex I
referenced last time this is the memes
of destruction essentially measures the
brain when engaged with novel stimulus
basically a zone of chaos fight or
flight but becomes normalized is social
media desensitizing us i don't
immediately know why the implication is
desensitizing i would say it is
resynthesizing as to certain things and
desensitizing us to other things am i
missing the meaning of the question I
don't think so I'm Emma I'm not totally
I'm not totally sure what what's going
on so that's the question I'm sorry I'm
just looking back I feel like Zach I'm
concerned that you started us off in the
wrong place here okay shall we go into
the next question sure would would love
to hear more detail of a hypothesis that
Brett mentioned on Joe Rogan how society
repeats patterns of opportunity
distribution what I said was it projects
them into the future so for example if
you have a population if black folks
accumulate in one part of town for
various reasons right because they've
been frozen out of economic opportunity
and the houses in that part of town are
more affordable something like that you
just have people accumulate as we know
neighborhoods do tend to accumulate
different ethnicities and all you have
that and then you have redlining right
and that redlining
creates a viscosity an economic
viscosity that prevents the accumulation
of further wealth at some point the
neighborhood itself has a small tax base
it can't produce high quality schools
the inability to produce high quality
schools tends to hobble the kids who go
to those schools it's not hard to see
how things that came out of Jim Crow
became ever more subtle and more
structural and might cause people in
that neighborhood to face a steeper
uphill climb to get to a different
economic strata right so what it does is
it simply projects the past pattern into
the future and thereby even if you do
away with the racism which we largely
have you still have a pattern as if that
old racism was still in force because
what you've done is you have not brought
everybody to the starting line and said
ok now that we've done away with the
racism and now that we've done away with
all of the consequences from it let's
you know let's run a race right we never
got there and so since we didn't get
there we can now turn a blind eye and
say well we did away with the racism
everything else must be the result of
the innate differences which it just
isn't you mean that's not to say unites
differences might not explain some of it
but we don't know that it does because
we haven't seen the experiment run I've
been shocked at the proclivity of so
many of my friends to subscribe
wholeheartedly to the woke mentality do
you think intellect and attention to
detail has anything to do with the
political choices people make so this
was one of these things I often
reference that Eric once said to me in
fact I think I've called it the smartest
thing anyone ever said which was truth
is the second best strategy and by that
he meant that social affiliation that is
to say signing on to what the group that
has power wants you to say in order that
it will share its power with you is
often a much better strategy than truth
so what it is that I think is going on
with those who don't sign up with this
it's one of two things either they have
correctly realized that they could get
somewhere in the short term by signing
on but they will ultimately be
confronted by this thing in the end so
it's not a good deal or they are
sticklers for the truth and the fact is
I think all of us sticklers for the
truth are I don't want to call us broken
but we say we do not have the circuit
that allows you to just simply socially
affiliate no matter what kind of
nonsense it forces to come out of your
mouth right some people do and the fact
that they say some crazy thing and
everybody cheers assures them that it
must be right mm-hmm
so anyway this can happen all over the
place you know there's some danger you
know in the case of Dave Rubin for
example that he's hearing you know the
fears of a bunch of people who are all
concentrated in one mindset and he
thinks that what he's saying is making
sense and in fact it seems to be making
less sense over time as he's moving
closer to a group that is united behind
ideas that are not robust closer to a
different ideology than one that he
formerly formerly ascribed to but seems
to be a jump from ideology to ideology
rather than to more first principles
thinking yeah and you know I've seen him
of late attack Chloe he's attacked
Josephine mattias there's nothing
there's no reason we know both of these
people incredibly decent incredibly
bright and incredibly insightful and
frankly open to other perspectives both
of them have that characteristic in
spades so why you know on what basis
could you possibly attack them well to
the extent that he is now moved in the
direction of an ideology that can't
abide voices like theirs he now can't
even hear what they're saying yeah if
the primary issue is the lack of equal
opportunity that disproportionately
affects black Americans could the issue
then be described as a class problem
that presents as a race issue any
solution must address both question mark
any solution must address both yes
I think his historically it was much
more of a race problem than it is now
but because of exactly what you say here
we have a socio-economic problem that is
unfortunately not purely by any means
but somewhat correlated with race so I
would say we have two populations for
which we still have a significant race
problem all right blacks and Indians and
it is intermingled
American Indians yes it is intermingled
with an economic problem it's a vicious
cycle and it of course demands a
solution that addresses both but I don't
think what we don't have is a an active
racism problem at large scale right I
have a race problem without a racism
problem and that is de ranging the
conversation because you know it it
would take an hour to figure out how
that would work and we don't get an hour
what we get is you know agree with us or
pay the price yeah there's a four blind
men and an elephant problem when arguing
against intersectional lunacy that's a
good way of putting it and I seem to be
arguing with each of them over different
aspects of the movement is there a good
one good way to unify and help them see
the whole animal that's it that's a good
question you know one of the things that
I tend to do is going to the source
material which is why I was quoting from
the actual black lives matter page today
that you know and it's changing it used
to have some differently egregious stuff
that's that's gone now but pointing out
what is actually there and the
inconsistencies within it is hard to
totally evade if the people that you're
talking away there in any way good faith
it's hard to totally evade that's an
incomplete answer though by a lot
yeah I mean I think the problem is we
all swim upstream to greater and lesser
effect because the people that we are
talking to are actively resisting
comprehension if they were even a little
bit inclined to comprehend which they've
been trained out of by all of these
Kafka traps they would see it because
it's obvious yeah they're pulling down
statues of whom right there
vandalizing Stevie Ray Vaughan statues
in Austin I that doesn't sound very
reasonable to me at George Washington
really yeah okay I'm aware that he was a
slave owner but you know he also it was
an important force and you know
far-sighted for his era but you know
that use of the word but in that last
sentence is what makes you a racist
right and but I know he was a slave on
her but right but I do know he was a
slave owner but I mean you know konrad
lorenz
an important person in our field you
know behavior yeah he was a member of
the Nazi Party right am I going to
pretend actually know that yeah well he
regretted it later in his life but it's
certainly a fact yeah you know and
George Washington was not a fan oh yeah
I see the you know first director of the
Museum at Harvard was I think a big
anti-semite yeah yeah and RA Fisher was
an anti-semite um you know here's the
crazy one you know Lindbergh thought we
should support Hitler and that does not
invalidate his crossing of the Atlantic
right so anyway history is complex and
the idea that you're gonna pull down
these statues why are you pulling down
the statues because it shows that you
can its power yeah it feels good in the
moment that's locked down for three
months and this feels empowering yeah
and you can't go to bars well I don't
you know it proves it proves what this
thing is if you can pull down a statue
of George Washington on video and not go
to jail right what have you just shown
you've known your boss we get it
where are we at on dark horse duo any
news from potential candidates or from
organizations that could help propel the
idea forward there is lots of buzz we
need to get our ducks in a row and we
need to do it quick quick quick but I am
getting contacts from people including
high-powered people who are very
interested in seeing this happen because
I think there's an awareness that we are
just in such serious trouble by any
other means
so anyway I'm heartened by the fact that
people are taking it seriously but this
is us this is now a public domain idea
and to the extent that we can elevate
its profile so that people understand
that this is not a joke this is not a
you know this is not tilting at
windmills this is actually an attempt to
rescue the Republic which is in
desperate need of it that's the thing
that's going to make it work so it's us
let's let's move would love to be part
of the IDW circle I crave these
intellectual discussions is there a
meaningful way to kind of get on board
and contribute well really a thing is it
it's not really a thing there are
subreddits you can join the subreddit
are a they're a bit fraught they get
invaded by people who aren't of like
mindset some of them are honestly just
out of steps some of them are actually
just trolls but anyway there there are
ways but I would say you know I would
pay attention to people who make sense
even when it's difficult to do so and
figure out how to have those
conversations with people around you
those are good things to practice and
maybe maybe something will emerge that
does constitute a community of people
who can abide by the same kinds of rules
that allow for an elevated conversation
that would be fantastic
just about an hour let's go through
three more the first one being a comment
long live the people wolf yeah yeah oh
yeah along with the people wolf you said
you were armed in a previous podcast
have you done any firearms related
self-defense training I recommend
Clinton Heidi Smith at Thunder ranch
near Lake View Oregon yes problem
everything under kovat is more difficult
yeah so maybe I'll try to get two more
in since those were comments penalty' my
question do you have any advice on how
to spot and navigate rhetorical traps
meant to paint you as a racist or phob
of some kind I don't have an immediate
answer to that
I feel like beginning I'm beginning to
have a sort of a I know it when I see it
since like is it a spidey sense about it
but I don't have a rubric that I have
formalized yet well I've got one it
drives people crazy though right people
want to say something does it well will
you agree that X right and even
well-intentioned people will you agree
that X and the answer is well that kind
of depends what you mean by that term
there I know from experience that's
where the bodies will be buried if
they're buried somewhere so anyway you
get very good about saying only things
that you know you can defend right and
that causes a kind of cumbersome
roundabout speech that people don't like
though I get to the point but what
you're really doing is look this is not
that era this is an era for people who
can figure out how to walk a tightrope
that you can't see and it's a learned
skill so I would just say watch some of
these things figure out you know okay
I'm looking at a sign it says something
you know part of me agrees with this
sign and part of me knows that I can't
agree with this sign try to figure out
which word it is that causes it to flip
just see get good at it just train
yourself and you know there's nothing
perfect but really the answer is when
many of us figure out how to evade these
traps the traps go away right if you can
show that you can stare down one of
these traps and not perish then others
will learn that thing as well and so we
need to unhook them one by one and the
mechanism to unhook them has to spread
all right we're gonna do two more
because the the final one is a is a big
question I think we should get two new
penultimate question to what extent are
jordan Peterson's views on the sovereign
individual free speech and meaning
relevant to this crisis and do you know
if he's returning soon
because views are highly relevant and he
is doing better and will hopefully
hopefully be back in the public eye soon
I think that's what we don't just ya can
say right now yeah finally why is not a
branded movement emerged against this
yet a way for us to stand together to
say yes to equality but no to over
categorizing humans are shutting down
ideas and speech pointing out the
warnings that history has given us this
would provide us strength in numbers
this is a terrific question
yep and you know there I don't know that
this is the right answer at all in it at
the very least it's only a part of the
right answer but I think that many of us
who are most loud at the moment also
have a real aversion to branding and
promotion and self-promotion and such
and you know are doing it insofar as we
feel the need but don't like it at all
and so you know this it might be easier
to get behind this if it was for you
know a movement as opposed to
individuals but I also don't know you
know none of us are expert in what kind
of logistical thing that would require
so like what but maybe the question is
why hasn't it emerged organically well I
think it is emerging organic okay we
just don't know enough to see it but you
know it doesn't have a chap jaws has job
doesn't it doesn't have it have declared
a part of the garden autonomous I don't
know if you noticed the sign I put up I
didn't know
well the slugs must have eaten no so
here's what I would say IDW was clearly
partially an answer to this puzzle
IDW was about figuring out how to
continue to have reasoned discussion on
topics where that was supposed to be
ruled out by these various Kafka traps
and it was wildly successful and I
cannot emphasize enough what it was like
to be on stage for example in Vancouver
with jordan peterson and sam harris and
lookout for two consent
of knives at an audience of 3,000 people
who you wouldn't have known they weren't
at a rock concert if you didn't know who
was on stage except no one's phones were
out yeah right
everyone was wrapped and he's amazing
they weren't really there for the
question of what is the nature of truth
they were there for something bigger it
was much more movement like it was much
more people interested in the idea of
reasoned discussion in an era of no
reason so in any case
IDW had a part of it I think rebel
wisdom has a party rebel wisdom has been
curating different conversations some of
them don't get along all that well but
nonetheless there's an idea that the
answer to this involves juxtaposing
these things and seeing if you can't get
them to play nice together yeah right
game B was an early version of well
we've got structural problems is there a
way to actually plausibly get from here
to an alternative stable solution that
is wildly more successful at
accomplishing what we claim to want to
accomplish so Jamie wheel has got part
of it apparently he and two of our
friends will be familiar to some people
listening or starting a podcast Jordan
Hall and Daniel shellacking Berger young
along with big think yep so all of these
entities but none of that is a branding
right we can point to these pockets of
such intensely reasonable discourse that
you know when it comes to disagree with
itself I can confront that and say okay
you know can we live with this this
dissonance or must it be resolved but
but in terms of a you know there is no
hashtag Beale I'm equivalent right but
so one thing that I've been thinking is
that all of these thing if it is in fact
true that we are going to bootstrap our
way out of this terrible predicament
rather than just allow the dumpster fire
to happen then probably all those
entities ought to coalesce in one way or
another and if they can coalesce they're
gonna do it hopefully under a banner
right at some level they are all
coalescing by virtue of the fact that
the audience that is hungry for that
kind of interaction bounces from you
know
the portal to rebel wisdom - darkhorse
you know it's doing that trick so the
question is what is the overarching
thing and in any case I don't know the
answer to it but at some level if
there's a political dimension here if we
are going to try to save the Republic
through a novel plan that interfaces
with our existing electoral system then
maybe that flies under a banner it
occurred to me I don't have the mug down
here but what game B was before it was
game B was the Emancipation Party mm-hmm
might be up there but in any case the
Emancipation Party that's a decent brand
because the point is it's non-political
right it's non-political si DW was
non-political mm-hmm and so anyway there
is room for a branding I would be up for
anything that caused the various loosely
aligned populations who are following
one or the other of these threads to
come together and say well actually you
know what we've all been sort of
separately preparing for something and
it came away faster than we thought it
was going to so now what are we gonna do
can we figure out how to get along yeah
I think we did it all right so um we may
be back on Saturday that would be the
usual thing but you've got at least one
maybe two pre-recorded excellent
interviews in the hopper we will be
doing a private Q&A on Sunday if you
want to join that go over to my patreon
and join and you will see what's going
on there
probably we'd be back on Saturday but
we're not sure but look for podcast out
from you tomorrow the next day yep you
want to say what it is yet no nope let
it be a surprise yeah all right
so you said like subscribe I did not
likes please like and subscribe and
maybe even
until we see you next fly low and avoid
the Kafka traps
you